science magazine presents a special
issue on plant genomes which includes an
online interactive feature with
informational graphics animation and
videos explore how plant Genome Research
is contributing to our understanding of
plant biology and evolution and is
leading to tangible benefits for society
the past decade or so of plant genetic
research plant genomic research has been
really focused on casting as wide a net
as possible over the plant kingdom that
is to identify those bacteria algae
simple plants mosses etc that are key
points in the evolution of higher plants
that is angiosperms and gymnosperms the
trees and flowers that we have in our
yard this tremendous diversity that's
occurred through evolution can be traced
back and really identified through fully
sequenced genomes you can see how
pathways have evolved how pathways have
developed and where the bits and pieces
for pathways have come from during
evolution having the whole genome allows
us to know what all the genes are and
what their different classes of genes
are and how many genes there are in each
class and this can be useful from the
standpoint of eliminating certain genes
or making good guesses as to the
function of other genes another great
use is that we can compare the genomes
of one plant species to another and the
plants within a species so across a
population and this is a very very
useful for understanding how genes are
causing different traits to occur within
a population or between populations
between species
read more and interact with the online
feature at WWDC is mag org slash
plant genomes
science is published by triple-a
the science society